take a look at kentucky
eight starts he's been very good he's
been very consistent
he doesn't allow a lot of base runners
only one walk to a right-handed hitter
so far this year
he does such a good job of
inducing weak contact pitching to the
bottom of the zone pitching around the
edges of the strike zone and letting
hitters aggressiveness get themselves
out
by aida facing frankie lindor who's back
in the lead off spot he'll swing it left
hand it's going to fly ball center field
deep back goes buxton on the track byron
with the play and pulls it down one out
base is empty and that'll bring up cesar
hernandez swag and a mist and down goes
hernandez and a changeup first strikeout
for miata well shane bieber will be the
nissan starting pitcher for the tribe
tonight and bieber is 2-0 against the
twins this year he's pitched very well
in two games at 120 era 5-0 in his
career and now a two-out walk here in
the first that'll bring up nelson cruz
he swings and a jam job pop-up shallow
center hernandez backpedaling the second
baseman makes the catch and shane bieber
jammed the heck out of nelson cruz to
get out of it david's second one out as
byron batts he swings and launches to
left field and deep back it goes and
gone home run buckston
a line drive pulled to left and the
twins take a two-nothing lead here in
the second and bieber has given up his
fifth home run of the year a slider that
just
really didn't do anything as donaldson
makes second base rosario grounds out
two down and now a chance for nelson
cruz to add on to a two-nothing lead
swung on and missed he got him to chase
away
and bieber gets nelson cruz here's reyes
certainly capable of tying this game
with one swing drive trailing two
nothing strike three on the outside
corner locked him up five strikeouts for
maeda and they strand one bottom of the
board and tomato with a good one going
for the twins tapper first base side
that's going to be fielded by maeda
he'll backhand flip it with his glove so
no that'll make the highlight reel right
there you see guys flip with their glove
a lot very rarely do you see them
backhand flip nice play right there
shane bieber trying to keep things close
indians trailing by a score of two
nothing as we head to the bottom half of
the fifth inning breaking ball swung on
and missed five strikeouts now for
bieber and ryan jeffers will step in
swing at a missed strike
well there you go the first pitcher in
club history to reach 100 punch outs in
his first 10 starts how about that
crews will bat now with two men on
and nobody out
big papa
almost straight up in the air
perez makes the cash cruise gone on one
pitch here is sano popped up behind
first chased by santana chased by naquin
chased a breaking ball in the dirt
bieber with a pump fist and he gets out
of it after the first two twins got on
that will prolong the inning now for
josh naylor chopper weakly hit to the
right side gonzalez now weights he feels
he picks he throws and just retires
naylor by a stride twins got exactly
what they needed seven brilliant innings
from kenta maeda now bieber with that
last strikeout
against byron has now struck out eight
or more
in all ten starts to begin
the season that'll bring up ryan jeffers
the rookie catcher has grounded out
strikeout the number nine hitter
swinging a line drive into left field
and deep back it goes deep it goes and
that's gone
ryan jeffers
hits his second homer in his young bigly
career a two out solo shot to left
and the twins have a three nothing lead
here at target field
436 feet another laser
85 elevated about belt eye
and jeffers sending one deep to the
second deck in left that is the u.s bank
home run porch
top of the order now and francisco
lindor swing and a high fly to shallow
left
rosario now drifting to medium deep left
makes the catch and now lindor and romo
going at each other and being separated
by the two teams
teammates
this went back to the last series in
cleveland romo loves to chirp and the
difference is francisco lindar is
bilingual he popped it up he gave him a
smile and then romo says something to
him right there and lindor responds
and here we go and thankfully cooler
heads prevail so that'll bring up jose
ramirez swung on blasted deep left field
this ball is gone
jose ramirez with a laser homer his
tenth to the seats in left and the
indians now trail
three to one weak round ball to the
right side fielded by rogers off the
mound he will run and did he tag out the
runner he did and that's the game
and the twins win the game three to one